hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to resident evil 3 it's
time to go find a vaccine for this
disease which hopefully is in this
hospital where hopefully a guy by the
name of bard also is alright so we got
plenty of ammo we've got plenty of
health we got plenty of flashbangs we're
in pretty good shape so Jill you take
care I'll be back
it's good seeing you by the way you
might be dying
don't worry about that old Biggie's
gonna take good care of you
interesting taro
where's Barda now hmm okay a healthy
family is a happy family
oh and that family sure do look happy
got everything about this is just a
little disconcerting when I looked at
the angle of his ami apocalypse so first
aids brain right here on the counter
lions a bullets Hospital cat why would
anybody need anything else oh I don't
have it I don't have that I don't have
that I kept bolt cutters for Jill you
don't think you don't think that I'll
need bolt cutters do you that face
something wrong with that all right
let's go what are we doing here what do
we need what do we do
uh hello got you
hey come on fall down damn it they never
fall down from the piddly little pistol
Oh
kaboom
it's always fun when that happens did I
get him - dude listen don't rush Oh God
I still to this day I'm not sure if
there's one spot that makes him explode
like it's a critical strike or if it's
just random chance I think it's just
random but it feels like skill was the
thing it really feels like I'm good
Oh lockpick okay so at some point here
Jill will wake up and Jill will be going
through here it's just not now excuse me
I'm sorry that's so hideously rude whoa
hello seems a little Bigford one body if
that's what that is it was kind of big
you know maybe like a nemesis or mr. X
as long as we're all good Oh God sorry
for the interruption
god what a weird assistant you have dr.
Bart that's very strange that that's the
way that that would be I don't
understand why but okay I'm gonna go
find these because I got nothing better
to do also what about this tape recorder
do I need to record someone mmm
dr. Bard hello okay
dr. bard are you in there I'm here to
rescue you open the door no voice match
found voice match what kind of sci-fi
[ __ ] is this
what kind of sci-fi [ __ ] is that
alright fair enough nurses Journal every
day they bring in more of these mystery
illness patients the sedatives don't
stop their delirium so we have to put
them in straightjackets okay and move
them to the isolation wing problem is
the isolation wing is already bursting
at the seams
the director has ordered us to admit
anyone with symptoms free of charge but
what does he expect us to do wish them
better we don't have a cure and that's
not all that's bothering me when these
patients die they're not collecting by
the usual mortuary teams we've been told
it's special handling to prevent the
illness from spreading but I'm not sure
I buy it
Miranda saw some guys wheeling a body
through the forbidden door during the
night why where what's going on good
question good question
peekaboo I
I am the best dan they can survive a lot
of hits to the nog alright alright I
have a funny feeling you're gonna break
that open eventually I knew that what
you get did you get for being a meanie
puss all right stars stars stars knots
got dressed symbol it's probably garbage
but I'd I never throw anything away so
I'm not gonna make really careful with
my ammo on I don't know why I've 232
bullets Hey whoa okay hey buddy you are
looking creepy that's oh there's
something oh there was something back
there - all right there wow you're back
up there you go oh there's something
else miss is that thing in there no it's
not counting that is in this room so
it's gotta be something in here what am
I missing
well I'm gonna come back anyway so it
doesn't matter right now there's
something over here
I miss that wasn't looking at that
wasn't looking what was that all about
hang on yellow door huh yellow doors I
don't like this hospital I don't like it
at all
okay so there's something on the other
side of the air we just make sure yeah
definitely okay why did you fall down
from where and whence you think that I
would be able to piece it together then
did you roll yourself down here and then
flippity-flop down the way that's a lot
of blood that's a lot that's that's not
acid that's a lot of blood oh my
goodness ooh anybody hungry
[Music]
didn't trust you for us.we
I probably should have gotten all of you
before but I did not see whatever green
paint why I don't see any green walls
lovely bullets Scott it just makes no
sense why there'd be bullets lying there
makes no sense at all just like the
noises don't make much sense at all Oh
handy that ah well isn't this lovely
lovely room hmm
there's Journal admitted over 20 mystery
illness patients patients in the
isolation wing exhibiting severe limb
necrosis fever muttering delirium and
signs of hyperphagia possible infection
tried every antiseptic still no blood
work back from the research wing ask
again doctor Yan was bitten while
treating one of his patients we've
disinfected the wound but his fever
won't go down nothing works
meanwhile the outpatient wing is
complete anarchy the patients are
delirious and growing more violent by
the minute we've called in our off-duty
staff it's all hands on deck now we've
got to contain this chaos do I really
need a handgun bullet is the handgun
even gonna do me any good so pitting
comparison all right I'm out here no
smoking hmm about that sorry I don't
know why I'm sober fee it's very rude I
apologize for that
all right who's in here come Oh more
blood more blood that looks like a
gunshot blast so someone got shooted oh
I don't like this
oh I don't like this at all oh I don't
like this oh okay I like this oh I don't
like this okay I don't like this none
I'm just being thorough because if I
check nothing I'll jump out at me okay
okay we're good a bit of a bloodbath in
here but okay
we tried I swear to god we did but
there's nothing else to be done the
chaos is completely beyond control
victims are pouring in now dying in
spreading the infection faster than we
can reach them so we've given up trying
those of us who aren't infected have
barricaded ourselves in here we can hear
the cries for help outside the screaming
but none of us will go out there because
it would be the end of us I can't
believe we've abandoned our patients so
we're sin imaginable for a nurse I can't
stop shaking but I want to live I want
to live 9:00 p.m. we heard a helicopter
flying overhead and immediately started
crying and hugging each other thinking a
rescue team was on the way but then the
sound grew distant and we're all left
with now as the moaning of the dead and
the silent screams in our hearts were
all about to lose our minds dr. young
Arianna Miranda Dakota I'm so sorry I
failed you
someone's coming help help what hello I
must remove administration ID cars are
not to be taken off hospital grounds
under any circumstances as per our
security measures all employees must
store their ID card in their own
personal lockers before returning home
for the day Kito locker room has gone
missing last person may have dropped in
in the courtyard until it's recovered we
have a spare key in the office please
stop by administration at the end of
your shift to borrow it
[Music]
I can't believe this garble okay there's
something in that locker probably the ID
card that I need maybe I can go ask Jill
if I can borrow her lockpick
well I can't mosey how could I possibly
mosey with that in my way
maybe I'll mosey down this way okay not
this way you don't know don't give up
man you give up that's not good just
checking better safe than sorry
coffee Oh peekaboo Hong Kong in the ball
boy gone right into partner sorry bud
well that that's definitely not good
coming out of both of those doors the
sickroom ah that's the sickroom oh good
good
all good note about tape recording I
think I know what happened to the
missing tape of dr. B his research
assistant took it one of my patients saw
Abbott removing something from a locker
in the nurse's station and walk towards
the treatment room I'll try to sneak in
and look during the night shift do you
just stay cool and keep you in your job
I don't care how important dr. B is to
the medical community that kind of
harassment is not okay I promise I won't
let them destroy the evidence he's a pig
and an [ __ ] and will get his day in
court
Wow someone abusing their position of
power I can't believe it who'd a thought
okay hello BAM get your head is floated
BAM
this guy closed the doors behind them up
light no I got you they're going the
wrong way are you gonna get me over
there stupid loser
oh no bunk there you go good alright we
all done we done zode we good we do
cheat okay good yeah yeah there we go no
I just was making sure that wasn't gonna
happen
rub your nose right up your snooze you
guys are done for good now good as it
should be anybody's sick in here oh
don't trust that you've done now you're
done no you're not God I will shoot you
straight up the butthole I will do it
and I will not hesitate sure of course a
hand grenade of course that'd be in the
sickroom Oh curse I was there anything
else in this sick room that I actually
needed like an ID card something like
that no all right fine then oh hey just
off to the Courtyard which I think there
was a drop off over here that I could
get down if there was but let's make
sure we're all clear that definitely I
can't do it for some reason it's all
rifle ammo okay so there's two drop-off
points does it matter it looks like
there is a hedge separating the two
areas so I am going to go through this
one Oh shouldn't have landed on my knees
perfect perfect birth even more perfect
than where
oh so there is something over there so
there's a reason to go up and around
alright I got this at least uh oh yeah I
know I forgot I could do that all right
look what huh okay got that now I just
got to get back upstairs drop stuff off
on the locker cuz I'm pretty full of
junk and then jump down the other side
of the courtyard
Frye's alright well that was he just
want some fresh air and I gave him
plenty of ventilation in his head this
records room is over here let me drop
stuff off real quick yeah I'm gonna go
ahead and go in the room I will remember
to drop down later but because I have it
and I'm right here might as well all
these guys are all gonna be backup
aren't they I got a bad feeling about
that but here we go don't like it my
instincts are telling me it's no bueno
my instincts are telling me I'm being
lured into a trap
[Music]
uh-huh nice hat thank you
nothing else okay all right here we go I
guess I guess wrong I was wrong oh he
would have had to have side step to step
inside that makes sense obviously who
wouldn't be able to open it if he was
standing right there oh that makes sense
I was wrong John
Ralph is mr. Ralph here alright Google
okay I got that everybody awake in here
good good good
stay down for a tea please okay there's
still that locker in there but I'll be
back that's quick and scary and I don't
like it
no no I don't like that none oh hi
what are you all right I got a full-auto
for you my friend
yep yep not him I'm not playing around I
don't care
oh god I punched him right in his face
your big dumb face
oh Jesus Christ I punched you right now
big dumb face you idiot oh my god I
didn't even know I could do that with
this character I was trying to dodge and
I forgot about the punching even better
even better although that guy was tough
took like two full clips plus a couple
poppers and then a punch to the jaw so
pretty tough I gotta admit
pretty tough not too shabby
okay so now that I got the ID card I can
open the places that have the ID card
but before I do that I am wanted I serve
blood there and then jump up what what's
going on here interesting interesting
no no that's not what I wanted to do no
god dammit
oh you suck ass oh god damn it oh my god
oh my god I've never been more
embarrassed in my life
okay and now we got the thing Oh what
did that do for me I literally don't
know what that did greatly oh oh ooh of
course that would be in a hospital of
course all right there's something over
there but that requires me dropping down
from over there I don't know how to do
that yet alright now I gotta go back
upstairs again
off B stairs e whoo buddy Looby loo
booty weed booboo or do I wait where was
the idea
more people there than there were before
oh here's big abou anybody operating in
here
anybody operating under certain
assumptions that they're gonna kill me
because they're not tell you that
straight up there's a lot of bullets
this is the bullet they pull out of
their patients with the picture that we
gave them you never know when we're
gonna need a home my god is this a boss
fight oh this feels boss fighting wait
why did they why did I wait let's they
just gave me an ocean of stuff to give
me a like an enormous amount of stuff is
that just a bonus to come down here as
if you would forget to do that which
maybe it is let me go back to the go
back here for one one second one one hot
second here oh yeah that's the intercom
I'm gonna go up and I'm gonna use the ID
card up in the room that I think that
the ID card needed to be used in and
then I should get a voice recording I
think that's the general gist of
everything that I'm going for at the
moment I go through here I go in there I
get the voice recording there's a safe
to be opened in here nobody messes with
me ever also I have grenades in Miami
I'll hold onto him until my inventory
gets full and then I will curse myself
for not dropping things off hello
[Music]
oh I miss the big frogs you guys are
worse
no wonder they shut down that other
program if they were making you guys
well I don't like that
I don't like that none something tells
me I'm gonna have to use my granades
yeah okay I'm gonna walk in there with a
granades and then we'll hi how are you
doing
nope no thank you
good care of that problem all right
more assault rifle ammo yeah I'm
probably gonna need it I bet I bet all
right red herb yeah well I'm running on
a space I bet I bet oh hey how you doing
buddy whoa what was that
all right Todd I'm a lesson one for good
measure mm one more all right cool now
I've got space in my inventory where
does this go
hello oh good
I'm here where is here oh here oh good
um so they're in there I'm out here what
if i Chuck a grenade oh sorry oh sorry
you did that me how'd you do Oh oh my
god you're dead Oh
oh wow that works okay that works out
real good turns out you can't get
damaged by the granades apparently I was
expecting two pieces of biggie
everywhere turns into lots of little E's
if you know what I mean
are you definitely dead is the question
should I be concerned
oh look a pie I could need to go in here
combine that with that nope we will not
actually won't give it a listen I refuse
and let's get out of here baby baby all
right
biggie coming through so there was
something that needed to be unlocked
there that something needs to be
unlocked here that's a safe that's
another Locker let me go to the records
room and then drop off some stuff okay
you ready you ready
you're a big dumb brain was exposed that
was your problem your big dumb stupid
brain you got to protect it turns out I
know how to hit it with the bullets no
drop off this I guess I'm done with that
okay Papa save we're doing pretty good
we're in good shape gang I need to get
down so I guess go through this way just
as good as any other and when I get
downstairs I need to use the tape
recorder on the intercom like I knew I
did I can't imagine that the voice
recognition in the 1990s would have been
too good cuz need I remind you guys at
home this is 1996 wow I wish I had a
grenade left hi hi hello I do it good
see all right
well I'm just gonna go for this
no no no no
there we go
now everyone's dead and they're not
gonna get back up yes correct correct
very correct actually the most all that
for a greener hey hey wait what did what
did we just talk about what did we just
talk about my friend well not my friend
I hate you we just talked about that and
yet you decided to be a big old [ __ ]
hmm wait what's whoa didn't notice that
before lost guy yeah no don't ask this
guy all right weird there's probably a
lot of environmental stuff that I
haven't been noticing lots of
storytelling in the world happening but
I think we got everything that we needed
besides this safe but I imagine some of
those things are only gonna be
accessible when Jill gets off her lazy
behind and starts doing some stuff
changing waste of a nursing degree of
course I have connections higher up
of course the military consults with me
on projects beyond your comprehension so
stop wasting my time with your nosy
questions doctor you didn't read the
documents did you know I shredded them
just like you asked good good good you
useless charlatan the best biologists in
Woodland no one's better than me yeah
okay
I thought I had an ego whoa whoa bard oh
he did oh he very did
okay bard uh bard EBU bard in ski bar
doneö he
jump up and bite me Oh Tyrell everybody
Bart's dead he's been shot I'm looking
well I was kind of an [ __ ] anyway
banquet invitation covered in blood dear
doctor hard it is my leisure to
cordially invite so much blood all right
you do a banquet on September 10th at
the Central Hotel where we will be
exchanging viewpoints on Raccoon City's
new special medical zone attending will
be Mayor Michael Warren chief of belief
Brian Irons and other distinguished
members of our community
okay the orient restaurant would be
honored if you join us Greg tester
United States Senator Nate I'll be
introducing the bill for that new drug
of yours in mid-august bring the cash we
booked a sweep for the usual after-party
you're a brunette guy right I'll let
irons know oh yeah yeah go pard yeah so
stupid a bass new drug bill yeah yeah
you like it lay right oh just one big
frat party I don't doubt that [ __ ] like
that happens all the time like
legitimately happens I don't like having
my back turned to this door here this
does this don't feel right all right
here we go email from Nathaniel bard
Greg tester Greg I know you're watching
the news this virus is going to devour
the whole country the dead will wash
over capitol hill like a tidal wave
you're not safe however you've always
been a good friend to me so I'd like to
offer you a way out I have in my
possession one dose of a vaccine for the
virus the Holy Grail and it's not for my
family not for my ladies on the side the
brunette's right no Greg I'm saving it
for you I know better than anyone that
you're the future of the United States
but if you want the goods Greg you have
got to get me the hell out of here now
without umbrella finding out lean on the
Pentagon for me I know you've got the
clout see if someone can get a rescue
team in here without you BCS involvement
you scratch my back I scratch yours
which is sound pretty chased after the
parties we've been to yeah looks like it
ran out
no this is VRC chief Nathaniel Bart
September 29 11 p.m. I am acutely aware
that my time's running out and I hope
and pray by making this recording and
bringing the truth to light that I can
restore some small shred of Honor to my
name all over [ __ ] City's suffering
again with the release of a biological
weapon known as the t-virus my employer
the umbrella corporation engineered this
virus and they ordered my team to
develop a vaccine which we did I keep
samples of this vaccine here in my
office the rest of it is stored
underground but those sons-of-bitches of
the board they want to destroy it they
don't want the world to know what
they've done so they're trying to erase
all evidence that the virus ever existed
[Music]
no another fool I know they don't want
me to don't want you to why almost like
they probably had I got you loo won't
walk
and she trusted me anyway am I good hey
calm down man
oh well that's convenient
great who knew that door was punch
activated and the secret was right in
that monitor I'm so smart and handsome
is it here is it here is the sweater
shoes it's just what about Shana's yes
that looks purple must be vastly a
vaccine which will cure a victim of the
t-virus hang tight all right Jill
hang tight you don't get up I know
you've been shot in the head but I guess
I can't do not to eat that I got it I
got it be careful
hey don't do nothing I wouldn't do
you think there you go that's right
that's fine
I could probably if I was feeling brave
out try to punch it it but you know I'm
not gonna worry about it definitely not
gonna worry about it okay there's
nothing else that I need I think I think
I could just go stab this into Jill's
heart and that'll be the end of that
unless she's worried around around kid
that the head is floating I hope it was
oh yeah that's a serious case of heads
frozen Spencer Memorial ooh
what a lovely place lovely just lovely
boom boom Shakalaka Jill Jill Jill Jill
Jill you're gonna be okay maybe I'm
hurrying Jill Jill I'm getting there as
fast as I can - hold on hold on big yeah
right
just had to write a love letter myself
hey how you doing yeah how's your heart
punk
Boosh there you go right as rain
never been better come on [ __ ] better
work it she'd better work did it
[Music]
tyro what the hell happened
attention all citizens the contagion
spreading throughout the city has been
designated uncontainable on October 1st
Raccoon City will be completely
destroyed in a missile strike all
residents capable of rational thought
are urged to evacuate immediately
this is not a test I met only a day away
there's still people in the city you
think Uncle Sam gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] here
they come what are you sit tight I got
this
okay yeah I got I got here sounds like
there's a lot of them out there you
didn't need that first date spray right
you didn't need it okay good I've taken
it just so you know just so I know and
just so you know I'm taking it all right
maybe I should bring my grenades I guess
it all up write another love letter to
myself you know just in case things go
awry I am the greatest my inventory is
huge all right all right Big D Big E Big
T I've gotta try to lower the window
shutters electric bikes better and how
do we do that
I'll try hacking you get the hospital
security system keep them on me in the
meantime Oh bud
oh that's a lot of them that is quite a
few hi who's first
what are we up here whoa detonator I
like that okay
now the fun shoot we get behind here I
guess I'd be good is it just you guys
I'm the best I'm the best I'm the best
no no no no no no okay it's it's big
film time it's it's big Fupa
whoa they they kaboom make a boom all
right
hey stop no man I wish I had more
bullets maybe I should use my knife when
they start dancing
I don't know who's Elvis PEZ easy-peasy
I didn't know that they weren't gonna
give me a challenge
oh [ __ ] never mind Thanks no take some
of this Ken wannabes oh they're not dead
okay okay flap flap Oh
it must be somewhere thanks bud Thanks
where could it must be I swear
oh okay this is fair yeah this is what I
call turn
Oh God okay here we go
yeah yeah that's right oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh
it okay let me go get this thing I could
have cut that with Jill's uh handy dandy
dandy do put that where's this circuit
breaker I say no to that
god I'm God man give me a challenge give
me a challenge my dudes my dudes my main
squeeze ease oh no oh
Oh God none of that none of that none of
that none of that please no I don't need
that opposite of what I need right now
thank you can you not do that scuse me
scuse you all right let me go grab that
ammo here I know there's some there I'm
gonna take a first ad spray I got plenty
of
wait but-but-but-but this is not a
grenade this is not a grenade what
[Music]
got you [ __ ] okay they're at the door
huh oh you're not dead are you I'm
detecting that you're not dead
judging by the fact that you're right
behind me okay interesting here we go
shall we do this is this is uh this is
big-boy hours there we go
where did he go is he not is he dead he
might be dead is he actually that
yeah what are you doing what do you
think you're doing what do you think
you're dead mmm that's right what do you
think you're hopeful one grenade for you
please one grenade for you please one
grenade for you please okay
here we go I should have I guess I
should have yep yep I understand that oh
my god all right all right interesting
interesting interesting interesting
interesting very interesting Wow yeah I
need one of these
I need my pistol now
[Music]
oh let me wait until you get over there
and then flaps good great
Hey
[Music]
I feel like that
I feel like that risk just like opening
up the whole area not even close
at least it's over I'm coming back I'm
coming back the long way
vaccine is the real deal
good you going somewhere you damn right
what do you think you're gonna do whole
city's about to be microwaved come on
call the government tell them we found a
cure you stall for time
[ __ ] and bother the balls on
that guy the big balls on him they're
huge huge cojones on that men wha
never seen a man it was a dream what's
going on this is what I'm supposed to
leave this city no no not like this not
like this
interesting
wait what a 33 shot nine-millimeter
handgun with a three round burst feature
it create a fire allows it to do a lot
of damage in short time well well well
interesting about that oh wait a minute
actually can I remove the dot from this
one way note exam that can I remove
reset no there's got to be a way right
right
take that bad boy off take it off take
it off
no way maybe I just don't know the way
okay so I will store that because it's
already has 33 bullets in it so like
yeah I'm gonna use that it probably
really wants me to use the grenade
launcher but at this point I haven't
done it so I'm not gonna do it for
obvious reasons that everyone can
understand this is a logical choice this
is me this makes perfect sense duh
I am very logical dude cool so that'll
do it for this episode of resident evil
3 thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down in the comments below and as always
I will see you
[Music]